you've been handwriting your work for
the past 20 years since writing the
baroque cycle what are the pros and cons
of handwriting versus typing for me i
started it as an experiment when i
started the baroque cycle because i had
noticed that if i sometimes if i was
stuck
having a hard time getting started if i
just picked up a pen
and started writing it was easy to
to go
so
i just decided to keep with that if it
got in my way i didn't like it i could
always just go back to the word
processor and be fine so but i never
that never happened so
there's a certain security that comes
from knowing that it's ink on paper and
there's no
operating system crash or software
failure that can obliterate it
there's um
i
it's a slower output technique and so
a sentence or a paragraph spends a
longer time in the buffer up here
before it gets committed
to paper whereas i can type really fast
and so i can slam things out before i've
really
thought them through so i think the
first draft quality ends up being higher
um and then editing first draft of
editing is just faster because
instead of like trying to move the
cursor around or whatever uh
or you know hitting the backspace key i
can just
draw a line through a word or a sentence
or
just around a whole paragraph and exit
out
and in doing so i very quickly created
an edit but i've also left behind a
record of what the text was prior to the
edit
of course you know all the digital
versions have those quote unquote
features but their
experience is different yeah yeah
is there a romance to just
the physical
you know the touch of the pen to the
paper
doing what has been done for centuries i
think there is i think there's a
just the simplicity of it
and not having any intermediary
technology beyond the pen
and the paper uh
is just very simple and clean um
and um
um
so i've got a bunch of fountain pens and
i i i started buying fancy paper from
italy a few years ago because uh
i i thought i would be more conservative
with it
you know it but it still doesn't it
it's still a trivial
expenditure so it doesn't really alter
my
my habits very much
you